une décision qu'il qualifie de
douloureuses mais nécessaires
jean-pierre sevestre a présenté le
mendiant septembre sa démission préfet
des yvelines
il met fin à des mois de tensions au
sein du conseil municipal de coignières
pour moi c'est la meilleure solution
parce que je considère qu'il convient
maintenant de donner la parole aux
poignets rien pour leur permettre de
hummer de choisir l'avenir de leur ville
sereinement après d'une préparation
d'élections peut-être qui intervient
donc plus tard et c'est une des missions
tout à fait personnelle et je considère
que pour le bienfait de mon équipe ma
démission je ne peux pas appliqué mon
équipe justement dans cette démission
c'est une des munitions une démarche
tout à fait personnel présent au conseil
municipal de la ville depuis plus de 17
ans jean-pierre sevestre est élu mais en
avril 2015
elle les premières tensions apparaissent
au printemps ou non du projet de fusion
avortée avec maurepas et se
cristallisent au mois de juin 2018
autour des choix de gestion de la ville
conseils municipaux ou le appels à la
démission après par l'accoutrement jeu
ses pairs en import d'une situation de
blocage qui pourrait justifier un autre
semble-t-il d'une manière tout à fait
objectif cette démission c'est que
mercedes a perdu la confiance de la
population perde une partie de la
confiance de ces deux-là gens parce
qu'ils se sont sentis un peu floués dans
la sphère de la fusion quand même ils
ont eu peur et perdu une majorité dans
sa majorité
sauf que je trouvais même la sortie peu
élégante plus il égratigne un peu tout
le monde
on flatte ans ou ceux qui voulaient
venir et enfin bon ok les cris au ton
très bon pour justifier quoi c'est une
c'est une bonne chose aujourd'hui que le
maire démissionne de toute façon je
pense qu'il était dans une situation
quasi impossible depuis plusieurs mois
ne pouvait plus continuer
je dirais à gouverner cette commune la
meilleure des choses aujourd'hui dans
l'intérêt de la commune et des poignées
rien ça serait une démission collective
et de nouvelles élections le préfet peut
très bien convoqué assez rapidement à
mon sens de nouvelles élections des
élections qui pourraient se dérouler
peut-être même avant la fin de l'année
en cas de scrutin ali bousselham et
didier fischer n'exclut pas d'être tête
de liste
l'intérim est aujourd'hui assurée par
dominique catelin première adjointe de
la commune
un conseil municipal est prévue le 19
septembre prochain